professor witty said people should be
prioritizing those things that really
matter to them this christmas don't mix
with people you don't have to
the prime minister then said we're not
cancelling people's parties or their
ability to mix
only one of them can be correct which
one is it
well actually if you listen to what the
premise has said in his entirety he was
also urging caution he was saying take a
test before you go out um you know if
you're meeting people check who it is
how many people you don't know check the
place is well ventilated everybody's
urging caution it's highly transmissible
so everybody is urging caution and you
know before i go out to any event i'm
definitely going to take a test uh in
fact i took one today hoping to see you
in person k but uh you know that people
will be uh cautious of course because we
know i mean most of us will know
somebody now who's uh who's got who's
positive with covid and that means if
you you know if you if you've tested
positive uh then you'll be in isolation
over christmas so that's bound to make
people a bit more cautious
don't mix with people you don't have to
we're not cancelling people's parties or
their ability to mix
which one is it
well make a sensible choice for yourself
make a sensible choice you know if
you're going to go to a party take a
test if there's lots of people there you
don't know if that's your priority fine
if your priority is to make it through
to christmas day with your family then
take a different approach everybody's
got different um pros and cons you know
so
make a sensible decision but definitely
wear a mask
and definitely um
you know
make sure that you take a test
beforehand and also try to go to
well-ventilated places as well
many uh i i've got one party which has
moved to to outside so uh hopefully
they've got some uh some some fire or
something outside or something just
forget to take your big coat with you
delicious um yeah can you take my big
cotton hat yes
even if you're northern you still need
your big coat this weather um can you
rule out more restrictions between now
and christmas day
we're not intending to make any more
restrictions you know obviously we had
the debate uh this week it was a very
full debate and you know obviously we've
uh we've made a you know we voted on
that and we we have um you know we have
introduced those but of course the prime
minister said you know if we need to to
act he won't hesitate to act and if that
means recalling parliament then then
that's what we have to do you know all
of us um are you know going to be
continue to work continue to be
available uh to make sure we get
everyone boosted i mean that's why we're
trying to go so fast with the booster
program as soon as we can get everybody
boosted it takes a couple of weeks for
that wall of defense we'll go back up to
where we were so hopefully yes it's hard
right now but hopefully we'll be uh
through the other side of this quite
quickly as we uh boost most of the adult
population can you guarantee that
everybody who wants to boost a vaccine
will get one by new year's eve
yeah everyone who's eligible that's the
target i know it's a tough target it is
a very stretching target it will mean us
doing more per day
than we've ever done but that is what
we're mobilizing for we've got many more
volunteers come forward we've got many
more hubs that we're opening we're
opening for longer hours
you've heard about some stadiums that
are going to be open over the weekend
everybody's rushing forward for it so
thank you so much to the british people
and thanks obviously to everybody
involved in the programme but it it you
know this is this is this is what we're
going to do we're going to it's a very
very ambitious target but we're going to
throw everything at it and we're all
going to be you know putting our hands
to the to the wheel to make sure we get
there are you confident that you will
get there
yes i think um the one thing i'm
confident about um and you know
obviously i'm a health minister now for
the last couple of months is you know
they they they can meet big targets the
the the infrastructure's there the
logistics are there obviously the army's
coming in to help masters of volunteers
are coming in to help um you know the
gps are obviously uh at the front line
uh you know 25 24 plus a million of us
have already been jabbed including me
i'm two weeks today so i'm hoping my
antibodies are quite high
yeah a daily telegraph reporting today
that the public have begun a
self-imposed
lockdown locked down by stealth is how
some are describing it businesses are
crying out for support we'll be speaking
to tom carriage later he's hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of cancellations
in his restaurants what support are you
going to offer businesses
well we do still have support in place
for businesses so we've still got v80
reductions we've still got business rate
cuts of 66 and we've still got recovery
loans in place and as i say we're hoping
this is quite a short period of time so
that we can you know get everybody
boosted and get that wall of defense
back up that's what we're trying to do
here um so hopefully we you know we've
got those in place till march or may in
some cases but of course the chancellor
keeps everything under review
okay how concerned are you about more
restrictions or even closures needed for
schools going into january
well again we've um you know that's why
we've introduced the second
dose of vaccination for 12 to 15 year
olds so we're hoping all those that
haven't been vaccinated with their first
dose come forward
and those eligible for their second dose
get those over the summer holiday over
the christmas holiday period teachers
get your boosters um that is going to be
the best way that we're going to
make sure that we can keep everything
going really whether it's schools or
restaurants or hospitality or you know
many many things will be requiring
people to be there so
they're the best uh that's the best
approach come forward get your booster
or get your job if you haven't had it
but hopefully that additional dose for
12 to 15 year olds will make a big
difference to their wall of defense so
you're confident that if the kids have
their uh jabs the 12 to 15 year olds
that all schools will open as they
should do for the start of the new term
yes
yeah we i mean you know we saw how
devastating actually how devastating it
is uh on the impact on not only
education but mental health and uh all
kinds of things uh you know and and when
the kids went back to school they were
so excited so no it's fully the
intention uh to
keep schools open and obviously that's
why we've introduced these uh you know
new precautions and also an extra dose
of the vaccine
okay and before we let you go talking to
my team this morning um and other
colleagues and friends everybody is so
weary they think they're thinking not
another christmas like last christmas
what's your message to a weary nation
thank you so much for everything you've
done for coming forward for getting the
booster for taking precautions for
acting sensibly for helping your
neighbors for helping your community for
volunteering thank you so much
have a peaceful christmas thank you for
taking the time and
look forward to seeing you in person in
the new year thank you and happy
christmas to everybody